aurélien voilà coup que voilà que
j'adore aurélien parce que il a un franc
parler c'est un garçon voilà que cuba
pour qui j'ai une tendresse particulière
il est sdf depuis septembre il a quitté
son domicile familial à cause de
relations très conflictuelles c'est ça
ou rien
oui après bon jamais de préciser je suis
pas vraiment sdf en fait parce que
j'adore quelque part en fait d'accord
qu'à partir de ce moment là on chez edf
battant des lieux abandonnés qui ont été
donc réhabiliter qu'on a réaménagé
ensemble qui sont menacés d'expulsion et
qui ont différentes procédures quand on
fait pour survivre
pas évident quand on fait un potager et
puis il ya des poules haussier qui font
des oeufs et puis il ya de la récup
plein de nourriture et du coup on
récupère toute la nourriture et on la
mange on l'a distribué aux autres
personnes qui ont faim et voilà après
pape en fait avant moi j'ai envie de
dire papa maman je vous aime beaucoup
si je suis arrivé à la rue c'est parce
que j'ai fait face à beaucoup de rejet
et aussi à cause des réseaux sociaux
parce que les réseaux sociaux n'ont pas
aidé c'est à dire que j'avais
l'intention de me racheter moi-même en
fait de regarder mon écran et d'essayer
de trouver une solution sauf que les
solutions en fait faut les laisser venir
quoi vous avez quitté votre domicile
familial pour du boulot parce que il ya
j'avais rien fait là bas moi j'ai fait
que répéter à ma famille que je voulais
être artiste pour faire de l'art en fête
c'est mou ils m'ont jamais vraiment
empêché de faire de l'art mais disons
que quand je m'exprime s était jamais
aux investissements et aux beaux-arts ne
sont qu'un petit oui j'ai été acceptée
parce que ben j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait
en fait j'ai rencontré des personnes
j'ai dit bah je vais m'exprimer en fait
donc au bout d'un moment à force de
rejet de passer l'hiver dehors qui fait
froid que du coup les gens ont peur de
toi parce qu'il fait froid que tu
cherches de boulot et qu'on te dis bah
non il faut une maison pour du boulot
que tu cherches une maison et qu'on te
dis bah ils font un boulot pour une
maison en fait c'est ça du coup moi
c'est comme si moi je vais faire du
ukulélé je sais chanter ben je vais
faire ça j'ai rencontré des personnes
qui travaille dans l'événementiel donc
maintenant le seuil de les suivre
c'est extrêmement compliqué avec les
mesures du coc vide et aussi avec la
peur des gens de se rassembler mais on
essaye quand même on est enfin j'avais
essayé de vous avez un permis d'arrêter
voir burger oui en fait
cet atelier on refuse donc l'association
qui logent les homosexuels à la rue est
en fait ils m'ont viré la semaine où
j'ai été aussi viré de burger king
c'était la même semaine que le roi quand
on lit ces des raisons en fait j'avais
un ami qui mettait des jupes et lui il
était pas au refuge parce qu'il avait
quitté le refuge mais bon du coup dans
un délire on va dire de s'accepter on a
dit ben voilà vas-y on va se rassembler
on va se travestir on va rigoler tout ça
et on fait dire ça a été très mal reçu
11 à 10 c'est à dire la directrice du
refuge de bordeaux nous a dit une
mosquée à côté vous pouvez pas faire ça
en fait
donc toi y avait plein de choses
négatives et un jour en fait je suis
arrivé au petit matin mon appartement du
refuge il y avait tout à faire dehors
sans explication ils m'ont viré et la
même semaine je me se fait virer de
burger king j'avais finalement réussi à
trouver du boulot après deux mois a
galéré leur quick-step à cause du
confinement j'étais à cause des rues
confinement et voilà on va être contacté
en janvier après une fois que ça sera
fini mais bien sûr y'a rien eu en
janvier voilà
et après moi j'ai ma part de
responsabilité là dedans parce qu'à la
rue je pense j'y suis allé j'avais une
volonté d'y aller c'est parce que j'ai
trouvé quelque chose maintenant j'ai des
personnes avec qui je m'entends mois
avec les échanges et je pense c'est pour
ça qu'il faut privilégier le contact
physique et c'est pas votre but là
maintenant aujourd'hui se trouvait pas
où trouver meilleur oui trouver un petit
emploi juste encore pour me tenir un
rythme que je la connaissais pas des
phases où je vais me dire en fait je
vais mourir de faim les gens s'en
foutent
parce que tous sont c'est faux on n'est
jamais vraiment seul et est ensuite
c'est aussi que les gens comprennent que
tous on est à la rue en fait parfois
quand je chante je vois des gens qui me
regardent et qui sont déçus et qu'il me
dise tout est encore à la rue ça me
déçoit et je lui dis mais toi aussi tu
as la rue en face de moi et pourtant tu
pars tu vas même pas me parler tu vas
même pas savoir qui je suis tu vas juste
et mettre ton jugement avoir autant plus
et ensuite partir et en fait y'a pas
grand différence entre les personnes qui
vont dans leur appartement et qui
descendent dans la rue dans les
restaurants et les personnes qui restent
beurre qu'on connaît pas trop où je
pense que vous connaissez pas forcément
beaucoup de personnes qui vivent à la
rue qui vagabonde qui voyagent à chiens
moi j'en ai rencontré énormément c'est
des personnes qui viennent de colombier
des personnes qui viennent du pérou qui
ont des trucs de fou à nous apprendre en
fait et maintenant il n'y a plus aucun
endroit où on peut recevoir ce savoir à
part la rue et en fait on est obligé de
prendre le risque de se faire taper
dessus par les policiers pour vivre des
choses comme ça moi ça m'est arrivé de
me faire taper dessus par des policiers
parce que je vendais mes peintures dans
la rue les exposés donc j'avais un mètre
carré je prenais jamais pris plus d'un
mètre carré j'avais aimé peindre sur la
s à merville me faire taper dessus en
fait ben voilà ce que c'est
du coup aurélien enfin je vous avais des
supers galère en même temps vous avez
aussi beaucoup d'énergie je comprends
que vous êtes inscrits aux beaux-arts à
la rentrée c'est ça oui j'ai été admis
mais oui on avait dit allez oui mais
j'ai pas prévu de il a besoin d'environ
500 jamais dû lui avait une bourse ou
pas alors oui mais jamais avec une
éducatrice de rue qui s'appelle hélène
que j'adore alors j'ai un truc pour toi
parce que ces derniers moteurs de la
soirée je vous demande d'accueillir un
grand monsieur grands chefs cuisiniers
yves camdeborde qui est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là il est temps de te voir
alors tu as entendu aurélien c'est un
personnage ah ouais je sais un
personnage il ya du débit les deux
matches pour quelqu'un de timide vous
impressionner bah ouais pour quelqu'un
de réservé vous vous passionnez la ville
et il est ici j'aime bien ce personnage
soit je sais que tu aimes bien les
personnages hauts en couleur aussi alors
il va être le mentor d'aurélien on va
essayer
oui mais je pense que cela m'a bien
match et tous les deux parce que yves
saint c'est un garçon qui il y lit pas
voyez l'exigent mais il est sympathique
et tu vois là tu continues tu vas être
derrière lui jean louis apprécié doigt
par rapport à notre métier de là c'est
ça la restauration c'est vrai que c'est
un métier qui demande la de
l'investissement de la rigueur et de la
discipline
bah oui c'est ça et je pense que des
cadres des fois qu'on n'arrive pas à les
trouver dans sa vie personnelle des fois
on les trouve dans la vie et
professionnels et ça aide énormément
alors tu lui proposes et si le tronc
d'un des sites devrait on a une belle
entreprise sur bordeaux la porte cailhau
rennes avant de comptoir c'est là on a
chanté cette semaine avec va venir il a
ses raisons qu'ils attachent entre en
scène
régulièrement on a besoin bon en ce
moment c'est vrai qu'avec ce qui nous
est arrivé dans le métier on a une
période un peu difficile comme homme et
comme l'ensemble je dirais de de la
france mais on a régulièrement besoin de
jeunes à des jeunes motivés pour venir
nous accompagner sur sur des soirées en
salle alors écoute si tu es d'accord ont
déjà de recevoir avoir un peu ta
motivation et essayer de canaliser toute
l'énergie que tu as avoir emmené en ont
le plus positif possible et surtout je
pense que c'est
c'est important de trouver des fois
d'entreprises trouver un travail
parce que ça aide énormément ça donne de
la confiance ça donne de la confiance et
quand ma confiance en soi c'est qu'on
peut on peut re remuer des montagnes
derrière rien cette rafale bienvenue des
cantons monorail ainsi formateur
[Applaudissements]